[Music]
Lona before he was pilot Pete ladies
this is the captain speaking I'd like to
welcome aboard bachelor and the bachelor
Peter Webber was a struggling student
named mark earning good grades in a 2005
Sylvan Learning commercial mark what did
I tell you about skateboarding in the
house
[Music]
we are living for the young lead school
is tough then still what help me read
better what do you think the old
commercial recently resurfaced online
and fans think some of Peters ladies can
use a lesson or two cup cute pajama
linger reset after the finesse Co of the
champagne stealing incident the ad comes
shortly after episode three of The
Bachelor
we saw the champagne gate sit down
between Kelsey and Hannah Anne I would
never steal someone's champagne I
promise you want and everything I would
not steal your champagne there was a lot
of drama this season and it involves
several of the women there's a lot of
layers Sydney calls out pageant girl
Leia for being fake when the cameras are
on you do react a little too much and it
looks a little bit fabricated which
ultimately led to the pilot sending the
beauty queen home but looks like a Leia
returns in next week's episode
has risen from the dead I'm here too I
can set the record straight about what's
that about me I'm obviously being lied
to by someone
[Music]